we're joined now by the deputy leader of
the green party Polanski thank you for
being uh with us thanks for having me so
we've got local elections whilst
approaching where are your main targets
what's a good night look like well
there's literally exciting opportunities
for the green party everywhere I've been
whizzing around the country for the last
few weeks mid-suffolk is obviously the
one that I think a lot of people are
paying attention to we could have an
outright majority on mid-suffolk Council
just to be clear that would be the first
time in the northern hemisphere that the
green party had an outright majority on
the council so that would be a really
big night for us but also we're looking
to extend control places where we're
already in administration places like
Lancaster Lewis Brighton and Hove but
actually there's lots of other councils
too I was on the world yesterday this
week I've been in Bradford Sheffield but
also quite excited about Worcester
Hertfordshire herefordshire South
tyneside as you can hear there's lots of
them
um you say that the Queens marketing
everywhere but let's get real there's
some and you've rattled off a few of
them where you've got a real chance of
breaking through others where let's be
honest it's going to be a bit of an
uphill struggle in those areas do you
think that green supporter should vote
tactically I think what's really clear
is when people see green councilors they
want more green councilors so that's not
the question though no no absolutely
tactically well no I think I would
always say if there is a green party
politician on the ballot paper then vote
for a green because a vote for a green
is a vote for someone in your community
we don't necessarily have professional
politicians we have doctors nurses
cleaners people who are in their
communities who have got involved with
politics because they want to tackle
both the climate crisis and the cost of
living crisis and on Thursday by voting
green that's an opportunity to have a
real Community representative in the
local election week everyone's getting
their expectation management game in
right so we have Mark Harper saying look
for conservatives we're going to lose
around a thousand seats and he had
Kirsten say no they should be making
gains they shouldn't lose any seats
what's the truth there is a lot of
expectation management going on watching
those interviews so in 2019 the green
party had our best results ever and then
it's only ever got better since then so
this should technically be a tough
election for us because for the very
first time we're defending that big
surge of seats we had but actually not
only do we expect to hold those seats
we're looking to gain even 100 more so
you can call this expectation management
but actually I'm really hopeful and
excited for the green party's chances
right let's talk about policy a little
bit shall we um earlier this year you
step back from an outright rejection of
NATO now NATO is obviously a nuclear
Alliance what's the green party position
on nuclear weapons then well we're not
keen on nuclear weapons at all and I
think that shouldn't be a contentious
thing to say I think very often in
politics it's kind of driven that
politicians to ask would you hit the
nuclear button I think we need to be
really clear how devastating nuclear
weapons are so with NATO we are still
very skeptical and I think it's fair to
say that we're looking for reforms for
NATO so for instance they would say that
they would never use nuclear weapons
first that they would put dialogue over
military action and I think all of those
things are basic Common Sense things
that would appeal to most people I think
we need to be really clear and we see
this uh with Ukraine that a country's
Sovereign right to defend itself in
defense must absolutely be there that's
very different to militaristic
operations that are often baked in money
and about governments trying to accept
just to be clear then what is the stance
on nuclear weapons then because you no
one likes them right no one wants to use
them but some people think they're a
necessarily evil do you think they're
necessarily evil or do you think they
should be got rid of and if you think
that why are you not against NATO well
I'd like to see them get rid of and in
fact that is NATO's own policy so NATO
nuclear Alliance though isn't it come on
well exactly and that's why we're
looking to reform in in their own
nuclear Alliance they talk about a time
when they would never no longer have to
exist and I think that's the place we
have to get to I don't think that's
particularly complicated I think we want
to make sure we're looking for a world
where we're looking for peace and
security that's not naive I think what's
naive is to continue in an arms race and
expect that to bring peace I'm Keen to
ask about hs2 as well high-speed uh rail
um what's the green party position on
high speed Trail so high speed rail is a
more complicated question because we
absolutely support High-Speed Rail now
on hs2 on that particular project I
think that risks turning Birmingham into
a commuter town for London there's
actually large areas of the north and
particularly in Wales that don't have
any real infrastructure at all so
essentially what we're saying is we've
reached a point where 40 of this has
been built already so there will be a
point in time where we have to say okay
is it now time to reconsider position at
the moment we're looking to hold hs2
limited to account to look how can we
minimize the risk of this but to give
you another example I'm elected in the
London assembly and I'm challenging
London Mercedes Khan he's building a new
road tunnel the Silvertown Road tunnel
that's going to cost 2.5 billion pounds
I've argued very strongly that that road
tunnel should not be built for both
social justice reasons air pollution is
a real killer particularly for minority
communities and the working class and
they often have the most toxic air the
mayor has insisted on building that
tunnel and now the diggers are in the
ground we've reached a point now where
it's no longer sensible to oppose it
we've got to talk about how can we
rescue it and get it um using public
transport instead just to go back to hs2
right because
if you're serious about green policies
right we've got to invest in Railways
it's one of the Greener methods of
transport and this is the big chance the
big infrastructure project and I get
that people have issues with hs2 that
there are individual cases things you'd
like to do differently look at the green
party why aren't you back here I think
it's bigger than people just have issues
on it it's incredibly environmentally
destructive there's lots of ancient
Woodlands that are being destroyed and
ultimately again it comes back to the
same question there's Birmingham to
London really need that new piece of
Railway infrastructure or did actually
like to play painting for the rest of it
couldn't you you could be saying look
why don't you we should be back King hs2
it needs a champion why don't you do
that I'm absolutely exactly more Railway
infrastructure that's not
environmentally destructive I think it's
really important that we have proper
nuanced conversations about this so we
absolutely support high-speed Railway
well exactly if the project is not right
then it's right to challenge it rather
than just back it on ideological grounds
and just finally what's your green
guilty pleasure are you meat eater do
you take like a flight every year every
year what's that what is it well I'm
really going to bore you because I'm
vegan I don't fly and I don't drive but
actually my guilty pleasure is saying to
people all the time so you don't have to
be vegan to join the green party you can
own a car and be in the green party
ultimately this is about system change
and the big change we're not about
individual responsibilities so I'd
encourage everyone to join the green
party on greenparty.org forward slash
join wow
if you managed to sneak that one in I
didn't even have time to cut you off uh
thank you very much uh indeed that plan
to get out of the Green Party